hey guys this is Vadim Angelica and Max
and Welcome to our blind unbiased camera
comparison between the brand new pixel 7
Pro the iPhone 14 pro Max and the s22
ultra now but he went out took a bunch
of pictures we have not seen them yet so
go ahead and play along with us and let
us know your results in the comments
alright so this is the first image it's
the basic 1X main camera what do you
guys like this definitely looks like a
tough lighting situation we have harsh
lights we have shadows lights in the
background uh I think I'm going for the
one on the left I like the warmth in the
face and I think it handled the
Highlights better I agree I was gonna
say that I see the most detail on the
the left one so the left is the pixel
wow nice pretty good moving on to the
next photo right here we have a 1x
portrait I'm liking the one on the left
the most the one on the right the cutout
looks really perfect but the blur is
just so intense it looks kind of fake
it's a little distracting yeah I
completely agree that blur looks like
it's just fake blur where here you
actually have bokeh you have the little
balls here plus
um he's brighter too and he's a subject
so definitely left okay looks like the
left is the iPhone here we have an ultra
wide actually like really close up Ultra
wide so what color is his onesie is it
really that color right there dude it's
actually like just gray that does not
look great oh it looks blue yeah it's
terrible there's like no detail in his
face at all I think the center one's the
best center yeah the center is kind of a
more balanced but I like the extra
warmth here so which one you choosing
left okay so Center's iPhone left his
pixel so far none for the s22 no love
for the Samsung
next this is a portrait selfie gosh
that's hard to choose
um well this is super detailed I almost
feel like it's too detailed no it's way
too much it looks like it's uh like over
sharpened I don't know like not pleasant
that the skin tones I don't like also
like looking at this it's all like
blurring weird with the hair didn't do
well and the shirt also looks not right
really smooth the right ones got to be
the right one right one that's the
iPhone yeah man the s22 looks kind of
really natural I think yep next one we
have wow I think this was supposed to be
a portrait the center one didn't work I
guess easily the right one yeah I have
to say right one I think the colors are
the best here that one looks like it's a
bunch of digital cropping I mean this
one kind of looks digital too that one
looks natural and realistic yep what do
we got as we do s22 on the right so
first one for Samsung and that one
actually has a 3x2 right because it has
a crazy telephone and a 3X it looks good
and the pixel doesn't have a 3X right it
doesn't yeah it's a pixel literally has
to crop in on that sensor all right and
this is video is that a video no this is
not a video that's not a video nope wow
well I'd have to say the left one
[Music]
I guess I have to say the left one too
that right there looks like it's all
smeared together that looks like it's
over sharp and yeah the left one left
one that is oh this is actually the 48
megapixel versus 108 on the s22 and the
pixel which actually doesn't let you
shoot 50 even though it has a 50
megapixel sensor it just pixel means it
this is a video this is a basic 4K video
so this could be testing stabilization
quality just everything in general
I definitely have to say the one on the
right right here look all this is
blowing out the white balance is off
this one was okay but I also had a bunch
of noise in the corners and the trees
that should not be there this is daytime
video so the right one's the one that
looked the best I think in every way
absolutely yeah that's the iPhone so the
pixel why does it have that noise I
don't know yeah it's a daytime it's not
even night time next up this is actually
kind of like a macro I had it really
close through this plexiglass or
whatever well the two on the right are
very similar not only because the eye is
more closed than this one uh I like the
exposures I'd probably have to say the
middle one you know yeah I think there's
a ton of more detail in the middle one
okay
that's the pixel pixel wow pretty good
next up this I believe is a 3X I feel
like the one on the right looks the
cleanest to me yeah it looks the most
natural I think the colors and the hair
and the face so definitely the right
nice and sharp that's the s22 so far
that's 22 is only one that was that the
3x okay yeah no Zoom shots okay this is
a 15x on all of them wow geez yeah
it's kind of hard that looks like the
original iPhone camera quality I think
the middle one I I yeah I mean it still
doesn't look great but I think looks the
best that's the iPhone wait 15x on the
iPhone 15x on the iPhone why does s22
look that bad I don't know was it like a
meeting it was kind of dim-ish lighting
indoors so this is cropped from a 3X
yeah that's a 5x this is a 10x did you
guys choose
wow that's crazy and next this is just a
basic uh One X shot as far as detailed
they're pretty close some of these are a
little blurred in the front because they
you know these ones have large sensors I
think just color wise I would just
choose the right one yeah I agree the
right one is the pixel pixel nice yep
the iPhone made it very cool yeah
usually iPhone's really warm and Samsung
would be cooler these are flip down yeah
all right next up we have another video
This is actually the portrait or
cinematic video mode so let's play this
it's at the Mobius Center in Spokane
whatever the left one is it is terrible
oh yeah it is horrendous oh the right
one what is that okay the center one
Center perfect you can actually use this
for Senate look he's focused the
background slowly blurs out you don't
have this insane amount of blur it's not
switching back and forth yeah right so
that's the iPhone iPhone that's the 4K
cinematic you know Samsung was first I
think they beat Apple by two years for
that cinematic mode this is an ultra
wide with the sun in the frame causing
some flaring there's only one that I
would want to have only the left one
that is whatever that is is
horrendously in the background but the
subjects are yeah it's like oh yeah we
got the sky here but look at the face
here absolutely the left shot is the one
that I'd want and that's the iPhone
again you know I've complained a lot
about the HDR not being good but in this
case I don't care about those guys yeah
okay next up this is a zoom shot all
right next up we have another Zoom shot
this is tough they're very close yeah
you know the HDR is a little bit worse
here but it's actually nice to have that
little pop of brightness and the fall
kind of Sun hitting it so I'm gonna go
for the left even though it's not the
most detailed so looking at them really
close the center one has a lot more
detail I don't like how on the left one
a lot of parts are like blown out we're
in the center one you can see everything
so s22 on the left pixel in the middle
no low for the iPhone no love for the
iPhone all right this is a selfie whoa
dang no detail there a bunch of
compression artifacts here and they're
just so dark on the right it's a tough
one because all of them have a little
bit of flaws yeah honestly I'm I'm
picking the left one yeah I was gonna
say maybe the right one and bring that
up but I think this is the better shot
overall so the left that's the iPhone
the iPhone I'm surprised that the the
s22 ultra it did so bad yeah it has a 40
megapixel front camera
um the iPhone has it's the same on both
the 14 and 14 pro Max but the a16
actually does better processing Next
Step wow 1X of the waterfall what's up
with that water
that's like before the Kool-Aid water
yeah that Center one also there's like
no detail if you're looking in this area
it's all just smush yeah Center one's
terrible I would go with the left I like
that extra pop of color and the white
balance is still right even though the
warmth is warm too you know I see a lot
more detail on it too compared to the
right one that's the pixels wow that's a
standard lens with ultrawide no standard
probably all right next up this is a
crop a crop of a basically 108 versus 50
versus 48. that Center one's really bad
and honestly that left one looks really
natural it looks really nice especially
compared to the center yeah left one
looks the least like it's a cropped
image out of the other one so left left
it's crazy that it's less than 50 right
way less than 108 on the s22 all right
this is a 3X oh that right yeah what
happened to the right I guess it could
even it couldn't take it not even is it
no there's no blur right and the blur
looks so nice in these shots separating
her from the the background yep damage
is worse in every way yeah even if you
don't count the blur it's pretty bad so
I have to go at the center I like that
and that space is is brighter here it's
kind of a bit too dark yeah the detail
the colors everything that's the I5
phone it's really good at bringing out
the glow from like sunsets and stuff all
right this is an ultra wide oh yeah this
is a tough one the one on the right is
really flat you look at the sign the one
in the middle I like the contrast but
then uh he's too dark so I think I'll go
with the left same left that's the yeah
again oh my goodness what's crazy we did
this comparison with a 14 plus against
the Seven Pro pixel and the pixel
destroyed it but now that we are using
the pro Max with the better cameras man
it's crazy all right this is just a
portrait oh kind of dim-ish lighting
indoors got some bokeh yeah this looks
artifacty it looks like there's noise in
the face even though the blur worked out
the center one looks too smooth in my
opinion just lacking detail Eli was not
happy yeah this one here has blur
everywhere look even up close there's a
ton of blur here even though the cutouts
will where these two kind of faded out I
don't really have much complaints about
the right one yeah I think I'll go with
the right okay that's the iPhone again
oh my goodness interesting yeah that's
crazy all right next up this is a zoom
shot another Zoom shot yeah why is the
right one like about in focus it looks
like it's out of focus everything was
good I just took a photo just like
everything else it's weird wow well I'm
noticing a lot of noise in the left one
yeah even though the colors seem maybe
better I I guess the center I'm gonna
still go with the left even though there
is definitely a lot more noise when
you're looking at on you know on your
phone that won't be as visible
so I think left okay left was the s22
center was the iPhone all of them 10x
it's crazy because the pixel also has it
has a 5x not a 3X so 3x still looks way
better maybe it just sucks at night or
maybe it turned it off and cropped from
the sensor maybe yeah yeah maybe that's
why actually all right another selfie oh
that Center one is non-focus but this
look it's like bringing out like all the
skin it's probably adding stuff to the
skin looks really weird but the right
one is so flat their iron's flat it's so
great that's blurry the right one's flat
I'd have to I guess left yeah I guess
left
left is the iPhone we guess we choose
that next up this is an ultra wide oh
yeah oh I like the center one look how
smearing yeah all of that in the face
it's almost like the shutters open too
long or something all the trees that's
another one that definitely has the most
detail like that tree yep compared to
that but also colors I mean I'm I assume
there's you know warm lights
so you have the white balance looks good
Center is the s22 yeah
it looks so garbage I have no idea the
worst one okay this is a 15x zoom Thomas
Hammer wow that's Center one Center
yeah these are dark and flat here the
center one the neon pops it gives it a
lot more awesome yeah it makes the
footage look a lot nicer that's the
iPhone iPhone should I stop complaining
the iPhone doesn't have like a five
times or ten times uh telephoto lens it
improves a lot from last year it's weird
right this is supposed to be a portrait
one of them for some reason refused to
take a portrait honestly the left one
popped out and
so natural yeah I think uh I like the
middle one better but I know if you want
to take a Porsche and Porsche doesn't
work that's a really sucky situation
I've had it happen a lot I'm gonna go
for the left one I like the bokeh also
it looks natural and realistic like a
real DSLR it's really good that's the
pixels wow yeah very clean oh this is
another video this is a cinematic mode
portrait mode but at night so it's a
little bit more difficult that makes it
harder yeah in every way so let's check
it out oh my goodness that left one is
garbage that right was it working oh no
there's a nice yeah it's a nice blur the
right one's shaky it's shaking it's
going side to side and these are all in
the same rig right yep you're holding
them all identity
who thought this was a good idea I mean
I I guess I know what that is because
you know we've experienced that before
that's
the center one is perfect nothing
's happened so far and with that the
quality too not only does the blur
natural uh the quality of the images
let's go to the white balance so
definitely the center okay that's the
iPhone just like I thought again I would
never use that mode on the pixel ever no
don't do it okay next up this is just a
regular 1X wow that right one just no
detail at all
smeary yeah a lot of denoising probably
I like the white balance better on the
left one the extra warmth but I think
the middle photo is the best yeah I can
adjust white balance I like how it has
some like blur in the background while
the left one looks way too detailed it's
a little distracting oh that's true
that's not a portrait it's just natural
blur natural blur
looks yeah
so Center yep that's the pixel pixel
interesting so now that it's night mode
the pixel's starting to kick up a little
bit it's nice it seems like it
okay you got a zoom shot right here
actually it's supposed to be a portrait
too one of them refused to take portrait
right there that Center one looks really
clean Super Duper Dynamic the left one
is so flat yeah it also looks like it it
actually looks like it's a nighttime
shot whereas this one does not look like
a ride-time shot yeah yeah and the right
one looks worse not only did the
portrait mode not work look at all these
jaggies right here all of that is a
bunch of jagged aliasing yeah
so does the pixel just suck at some of
these portrait shots I don't know oh you
know what it is when you take photos
with the pixel it doesn't show you the
portrait at all beforehand you take a
portrait it tells you it's gonna work
and then only later once it does all the
processing five six seconds later if you
go into camera you can see whereas with
these other two it shows you oh
that's a big difference well that left
one's very impressive yeah the left
looks great the sign looks look the sign
is actually it's red the science yeah
why did it
that is gone the inside I like that
lighting the warmth definitely looks
like lift that's the pixel wow the
iPhone changes iPhone made it yellow
there's some color but it's not right
that's pixels
fire fire pit
[Music]
dude what is all of this yeah I don't
know what happened I actually tried
multiple times and I get the same weird
artifacts yeah this is a lot of
denoising but the HDR work that looks
amazing the HDR didn't work well here
but you have a ton of noise and then
there's that one that kind of just
exposed for the Flames now I mean if I
was gonna keep one in my phone I think I
would pick the left one the right one is
just not a really pretty picture
honestly the left one looks pretty cool
yeah I would probably pick this if I
needed to bring down the Shadows a
little bit not that dark but yeah the
left one okay left one's the pixel
pixels
the pixel's catching up you know what
this is the crazy 108 sensor is hard to
do all the software stuff on probably
shot probably yeah oh okay
similar situation set up a little
projector that we're testing
that looks bad noise artifacts yep that
looks bad yeah I would go for the right
one the right one
yep okay right one is the pixel gang man
if you're taking tough shots at night
the pixel is doing great I'm catching up
too oh this is gonna be a video video
Pitch Black with a fire and a projector
you can't get any harder than this let's
see it see
oh my what's all this streaking lines
that has a ton of noise that has
shrieking lines
that one actually looks
usable yeah
dude it's a whole thing but that's all
blown out oh those are oh yeah okay so
absolutely the one on the right I can't
believe it actually looks that good yeah
that's the iPhone how does Apple do so
good with videos yeah it is crazy sort
of that noise and this is the last photo
astrophotography here there's barely any
stars
yeah at all right just no detail
anywhere really
really yeah and then this has the most
stars definitely
it's a little darker too darker here you
have the blue that one's just so bright
it'd be yeah but it's too bright it's
like Daytime Nighttime so I'd like this
to be a little bit more blue but I think
yeah the middle one so
and that's the pixel now I do want to
mention that both the s22 and the iPhone
had a 30 second exposure while the pixel
had a four minute exposure it took
forever I'm just sitting there waiting
like come on man
but it looks good but all the stars got
brought out it's not too bright yep so
that was it all right and while they're
counting their tallies you guys do the
same thing comment down below the scores
that you got before we reveal what we
got so we have our scores and I just
want to say that I'm just shocked by how
well the iPhones uh 3x lens cropped even
to 15x looks so good it has to be that
extra processing so once they release an
actual 5x 6X or whatever even better
it's gonna be nice I
um I thought it was really interesting
how the pixel and more like the middle
lighting did really bad in some of the
shots but then at night time it's like
fantastic insanely oh yeah I got a bunch
of extra points right there
so good at night so we have our results
here make sure you guys comment down
below and from me I got 12 for the pixel
17 for the iPhone and only four for the
s22 ultra Angelica what'd you get I got
11 for the pixel 19 for the iPhone and
three for the s22 man it's crazy at the
the s22 just a few months ago was
amazing and it's not that it's terrible
now uh but the other phones the pixel
got so much better and the iPhone got so
much better and if you guys haven't seen
our comparison between the pixel 7 Pro
and the 14 plus which they have the same
price you guys need to check it out
right over there uh the pixel does a lot
better against that phone so thank you
guys for watching hopefully you enjoyed
this video and if you did click the
circle above to subscribe for more more
like this one this has been Vadim
Angelica and Max and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]